[Music]  Kalani explained me how importance of me  and her spending time together without  the boys wow that looks beautiful yell  so ever take my wife as a romantic date  thank you  smell it so good that's none of my love  oh alright  chocolate that's the sweet of my house  where I want it thank you  today my mom will be watching Oliver in  Kennedy so that I can finally have some  alone time with my husband yeah another  more I'm very excited I have no idea  where we're going on our date it's  supposed to be romantic and that's only  now I feel like giddy  you know what giddy is Kitty is like I  just feel so fun and like like carefree  kalani and ah swell ooh lovers without  children right now  [Music]  yeah you ready baby girl where are we  you say that you're gonna throw  something what do you think that's your  romantic date yeah baby  [Music]